[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my day job is working on telephones
which is a member of hero fans
subscriber one isn't okay
[Music]
[Music]
willing to the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so policy one of the provisions in which
the 2015 plan it was a pleasure to
freeze the you a teaspoon that was
frozen at 6:15 that research point
appears the beautiful ending Church
reach the pointy 25 to see covered roads
[Music]
there is what the staff able to find and
set up the red stripe on the basis of
[Music]
so anyways changed in we announced in
last year and so these valuations have
used latest strike and differences
increase in property same rating period
so good example was the most of us the
most Lots have increased
[Music]
those properties thank you Steve
and that is just personally I'm either a
victim or beneficiary which shipped an
evaluation so my rates will be
substantially the other than we are
innocent correspondingly the veneration
has changed as well
okay counselors there will be some
questions in observation and I think
that's good and fear that we went
through any any issues that counselors
you know that we've been disappointed to
read it last week where we had the
problems we had and then I sort of read
through it again this week and we've
actually nailed that a bigger increase
from the rule right then we had last
week it's moved up to four point nine
seven percent of the rate take an
increase in the rural area and sort of
for the workshops the two point eight
four percent of increase and no
explanation hell would be spread and
would have been nice to have that
happens back at the workshops and they
have some discussion rather boy Steve
has explained it well well whatever
landed but this is a you AGC at the
maximum of 25 cent this year is the
question and changes in the community so
we need some of those things are
spilling over and they're going to
continue to spill over is the service
building and democracy and it's spilled
over quite largely this year and it will
probably continue in the next two or
three years unless we change something
in the LTP
[Music]
which is dead but you maybe see kept a
25% to the actual maximum possibly
interesting and anything that still is
Reebok kappa better and I guess with
properties track differential changed
and the Kevin one was a differential
change in the capital value the
differential from last year to this year
and Cameron values between the town and
Roy was changed from 40% to and it's
gone up to 1%
[Music]
I thought the channel writing to say I'm
out over all the cabins value in our
district but it seems to be even think
it's trips with them the winners from
and there's a lot of techniques or
inspiration to tender to potentially
apply the application as pilot funding
review they go through and they told us
so we can't change that at this meeting
or to know because to two-thirds
[Music]
in the key provision really technology
is 102 feet which is you may have been
the policy after consulting on opposing
meanings that give us a 692 which is so
and I have actually spoken with
preeminent so that's something that you
really to do the process in the green
people when you end distance change made
to mitigate that effect then pop up
somewhere else and and they give us a
price you just don't saying whether but
the surprise was we were sort of led to
believe it was 2.4 percent rise average
which it does but has not been speed for
eagerly announced that energy of the men
was about driving their costume we
removed about 650,000 they are budget to
get there or so and we didn't really
let's just start on the street you don't
listen to me
I was until very very late in the piece
that because it even cost appreciated
frustration and is and this is these
type of discussions around somebody's
sitting invited to to look at how we can
change things around
this is always policy
doing this it is complex
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there is no in my mind and in my
experience I guess that's always gonna
be challenge when you're dealing with a
land-based effects which is what rates
are these are chemical chemical takes us
certainly there's nothing fear about it
not because like so there's 23 percent
of the you know holders pay 65 percent
of the cost if we learn to it's a venue
but not a earning capacity just really
wish and obviously with the various
country that could proceed the relation
to health we mean it up here today
particularly around and unvarying
excellent fingers how do we actually
Christian see how do we with my
confidence or reassurance to the
community around the questions that are
asked not least there's positional gank
going toward what we look particularly
around the now being to have the right
balance across the right past not
necessarily a select group the right
presents a
- there is no when you get into it you
will find there it's really hard to find
this people can feel then create a
reason feeling and rates but my biggest
encourage that is to use for counselors
do two things one is to really get
involved and oh ratings will not be
Teresa for some people but get involved
in the mechanics of it
so I know that kidding kids around the
challenges going forward is a time
consuming and will be a number of
workshops they're going to go for civil
heirs there's going to be councilors
when it comes to rate sitting in four
months time you can have confidence not
only in that structure of the
organization in your own he thinks
you're a chef but I'm concerned as to
where we find ourselves it was a mistake
and
and extraordinary circumstances see if I
change a flood significant flood covert
19 and they're just endorses very viable
small team we pride ourselves on keeping
costs down especially wage costs but
there are consequences of that I'll
spend some time on this sin I've got a
bit to say so please be with me but some
of us will be repeating what's already
been seen but I just want to reiterate
the read of the revenue and financing
policies civil 2018 this is the third
year that we are rating under their
policy for the past two years we rate
increases have been between 1 and 1.8
percent less than urban rate increases
18 19 wonders in this 19 21 28 seen this
we didn't hear from Peter out of farmers
one could conclude that their federated
fan is only concerned when the increase
does not suit them we are elected to
represent all rapists not just one group
the revenue and financing policy is
delivered the right mechanism since 2018
and I understand that cannot be changed
or cannot be manipulated what has
changed is the and the independent
evaluations of property by QV we don't
have any employers over TV we don't like
the office and don't want the constant
is roulette if a property is increased
in value of course their property will
attract more rates based on to the
driven rate increase not at the rate
stripe that we went out and published in
these rating examples on page 55 54 and
55 there is a swing and different rating
babies there are winners and losers but
those winners and losers sit in the
category so looking at dead there's
worships perhaps $800,000 capital value
rural lifestyle property experience an
8.5% increase according to the table the
other rural properties will benefit from
having paying more whoever is rural to
rural urban suburban and I'll speak more
about this title
I could take a 3-year view on the rate
increases from 1819 turn this annual
plan urban I've had an average rate
increase of 4.5 4 and 4.50 just about
the same go graph here showing that
there was a mistake in the first example
when the rating table but it seems that
some quarters are using this for sake as
an opportunity to incite civil unrest
between and a divide between Mary wasn't
wrong
and then annoys me and also find the
insinuation of a rating manipulation by
staff is unpalatable if we as counselors
find ourselves due to the lack of our
own understanding or research unable to
inform the questions has this lead to
the to the statement and federated
Farmers leader if it has we are the
staff an apology if the accusation is
greed I believe that amounts to fraud
and as chair of the order of Risk
Committee I need any counselors to
inform me if they have any evidence of
sexual this is serious to to manipulate
the UAE GC to deliver a higher increase
to the law of their you properties and
those problems are often occupied by
those on fixed lower incomes as a
complete contradiction to what this
council seat back in 2015 I know that
rates represent 1 to 1.5 percent of farm
expenses farms can claim GST that the
text adduction they only pay one GE ADC
for their home and for their business
please keep this in perspective and make
a decision at a right time all of the
information and also recall an
opportunity distant past the submission
by David Cooper obliterate of the
farmers actually said that Gore was one
of the first to world rapists the rating
examples on 54
fifty-five of the airplane do shows a
man experiences and I would personally
get a problem with the way that table
and compare the data is used then bit
data that you're looking at on their
page compares compete the probably
towards former CV so that's the $800,000
property you see in front of you is
showing an eight point five three
percent increase is actually comparing
it to where there was a seven hundred
thousand dollar property in the last
annual plan so that 8.5% increase
includes an additional hundred hundred K
of chemical values rating not driven by
this counseling if I compare the same
property apples apples last year an
eight hundred K property to and 800 K
property the increase is two point two
three percent more in line to what we're
expecting to receive that to meet this
apples events I'm not finished
I've spent a lot of time in this and I I
stand by my research anyway I would
guarantee that very few councils around
the table including myself would
understand that approached at least they
spend certain amount of time researching
it I'll be supporting the the motion to
adopt the annual plan but I do get one
point of questions and these to the
chief executive the suggestion the staff
have manipulated the revenue of - in
policy what are the consequences for
that for the staff for the council for
us underwater and I do recall the
previous years we've gone through two
significant links to get a legal opinion
on a rating
resolution - insurance career so what
happened is effect insinuation is the
calculation
from the directive of the Penal who
rightly believes that to race it's like
a formal taxation and these to exercise
authority and history accurate so it's
just no reason why staff do this is no
it just doesn't make the is the subject
of particular parties each year we know
around and currently there and this
building who in terms of just following
on from a council files question around
seventeen fifty years at a last meeting
we did result that the order dress
committee would be involved in some form
of forensic review of the process to
give some certainty around the numbers
yes
I think it's in that resolution there or
is it something we should be considering
tonight iced teas statement here we can
surround this table his own strengths
castle hoisting strength is in the
accounting cycle he has looked into this
city city the last three guys we
received a phone call today from a white
cake a reasonable that's how I was going
to vote
we headed to plate the debate was around
how how the system worked
I told him what I knew told of my
strengths for not accounting based but
it was extremely feed in my new but
we've been doing for a number of years
the same way also
unfortunately due to the flat jutsu code
of 19 we didn't it scarcely seen around
the table we could be a chance to have a
look at it spreadsheet before that's
printed and they can take care of
gathering among others he was the first
one to pick it up and toilets whatever I
was he told that if I guarded their own
way my business would be targeted and I
won't receive business from the in
person and also other people belonging
to his organization I'm not sure that I
believe is coyote Red Cloud's I haven't
signed out to the council but it's a
rubbish I saw it out to do a service to
the community and we all sit here and do
it at least and we come in here and we
do the beats for urban we do the base
for room and we do the basement
commercial so boy something happening
why this really gets up one writer as
you peep on my voice from quotation
betters
this piece of private there has been put
in front of us today's just to show that
this wasn't in the airplane
I'm saying it's anyone's fault but as
you can see there's a teen area which
increase its very feet absently as its
council how is it close yeah sometimes
I'd only industry means on page two
because it's basically I will be voting
for the legend
thank you
each council forever friends and you are
correct some of the safe streets in some
of your subjects trains them to not
appear but it does to me when you get to
bully technics like you've seen in the
last days we stand over tactics both
street names of businesses is put in
right and not on Satan's me it makes me
man there's no place in this council and
a more enthused by since community just
just a farmer state's not a federated
Farmers and pinion to do that it'll
individual there's an individual's
opinion I'm sorry to say was I to do
just as counter it breeds opinion about
the percentage increase over the last
three years
nine if you turn those percentages into
dollar terms per unit right higher all
right over the last three years I think
you'd funded the rural ones ever bigger
quite a large dollar increased for
writing you know compared to the urban
even with the GST out of it and even
with a business energy and I think over
the last two years I've been quite happy
with the rate increases because you look
down at the dollar entries which is in
the last column no one has looked at
this and that has been pretty fair over
the last two years this year totally
different and I picked up they've
mistaken this a team to two weeks ago no
one else picked that up and I let the
counselors know I didn't I informed
federated Farmers to read their genius
and that's as far as I think week the
ferret pharmacist a window further I
think emailed and we'll see what they
communicated last night I really and I
kept the layout of the in discussion
they have made their own opinions and
individuals have probably made opinions
beyond what federated Farmers spin for I
do not like to see federated Farmers
rub-rub through the rubbish to say that
they are accusing council of fraud
what they're doing and but there is no
[Music]
progeny of on frying a permanent bridge
I didn't go to the media like I did the
right way just just to respond on they
John the leader from Jeffrey young to
counsels paragraph five and six meeting
yet the last see cumin third last
paragraph suggests that there's been a
change in allocation egos more
concerning is the indication on these
changes they'd be made without
counselors being informed these changes
reflect that clear and deliberate and
teach them to increase the race paper or
a pass should have benefited other
ceases and it is not clear that the
council's had been made aware of these
changes so that's the basis I made that
comment links pretty clear to me
let's not fordable young age I think
he's asking the question the changes
reflect that clear and deliberate and
teaching to increase so to me that's
it's not a question it's a statement we
have a revenue on financing policy there
is insinuating the staff are
manipulating best food that's ordered
sorry I think it's definitely different
we let this table we're in it together
yep and there's no one as losers around
this table we've got to deliver the best
possible outcome from a past I know my
statement has been real secret but Lea
tech has been from world but I leave
here all represent anyone that calls me
or talk to me as long as it is written
my business or what I stand for my two
main projects since the last round the
rate and when was the permit bridge the
other is for grant right they will be
able to impact on their rate increase so
that's something new kind of taken to
account that it did surprise me last
week models of tables and sort out
differently weird being a newbie
counselor and just looking at the best
having rights to see that just surprised
me and I was looking at council calendar
rings and tell me that was a big mistake
and I was comparing it with last year's
what I personally do is deafening
they're right and when even counseling
him standing this so we endured until
Ashley's all right and so having even
that would install even in this time I
stood you know what I've CTO mock was an
explanation why some was negative T and
someone's positive light that's the
writing there's variations of the
valuations as causing those wall
challenges competing with last year's
raising K which was very funny and see
Steve's even with many areas it's not
just one comment we didn't discuss early
on the pace of air using the rule fund
that the rule the counselors put unto
you to actually lower those loans
nothing was actually done about that we
thought about print
[Music]
animals used to build a roundabout to
their hamster boy there were two main
bridge near and I think there's quite a
lot of debate I was known council then
that's something like the permanent
bridge would be shared evenly amongst
all the real rapist and would help
alleviate page 69 as well as a finger
problem in table tells an unwritten rule
[Music]
doesn't the third column doesn't need a
subscriber three four is the rule great
high as when you're going to happen to
63 we complain you NGC I think it should
be 16-0 missing this should be one sexy
ones remark like this or is these all
these families that are listed on page
71 how many of them were met by the
money warmers I don't know where they
are on a balance sheet Council of six
five reduce it means replacement and
maintenance of reserves both equations
[Music]
which is the sleeplessness on a big
number
cash reserve accounts actually
absolutely Hitler one time one night we
had fight went to city were sitting
around I guarantee you haven't felt
something in the equity year at the
balance sheet the m60 waiting here it's
communities
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
clarifying information council
what does things are showing that some
of us have been subject to some homeless
probably don't realize that we all come
to the table I think a section on some
people
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the document clean fill waste the
tonnage that comes out of corn for 2014
10 is 6022 times tonnage I haven't we
it's least and mean as you can see it's
gone because sometimes it won't be -
matheran - think he wants to I think it
was a material side of the durian cool
it explains it in these I'm just lost
which page it is it's just as just a
meaningful mistake that they made the
wire on this
he's got Paley's bins as operated in
they based in the garden stock page then
his bins of the Goguen surrounding areas
there should we do one page 30 of the
document
[Music]
[Music]
the city is going given that a huge on
the agenda the rates are going to be
quite a challenge to manage is coming
from around the five levels that we can
but again some of those children's the
council's of